Speaker 1: All right, so before I head out on a
brief break, I do want to touch on the fact that
it is August and that has some relevance.
We're going to have some great guests host
coming up. Faran Cousins will be filling in
for me, Jesse Darla Moore. But before I leave,
it is August. And supposedly Donald Trump
is being reinstated in August. Yesterday,
I spoke with my pillow guy, Mike Lendell, who
says it'll be August, maybe September. It'll be
the Supreme Court, probably. But who knows? But
to step, step back for a second from Mike Pillow.
The real question many are asking is not whether
Trump will be reinstated, he won't be reinstated,
but whether his followers will become violent
when he doesn't get reinstated and whether
his followers will try to stage a second
insurrection. Now, yesterday, we looked at
clips of an organization that says they're going
back to the Capitol on September 18th. There are,
I think we can say conservatively, millions of
people, like maybe it's not tens of millions, but
it's certainly millions of people, followers of
Trump, who have been led to believe by any number
of others that Donald Trump will be returning
to the throne, as it were, somehow this month or
next month. It might be through the Supreme Court,
it might be through the generals of the military
doing something nebulous that we don't understand,
or it'll be because something incriminating will
come out and Joe Biden will resign and so will
Kamala Harris, which, by the way, wouldn't
make Trump president. Right. I mean, Trump is
not part of the line of succession right now,
or maybe they don't even know how it's going to
happen, but they think maybe it will, but it won't
be happening. And so then what? Among the 50 plus
attendees that Salon spoke with at CPAC in Dallas,
more than 40 percent said they believed in
August Trump would be reinstated somehow.
What do they do when it doesn't happen? Some law
enforcement agencies are paying attention. Zachary
Patrizio writes in Salon that quote, On July 13,
Bloomberg News reported that Lindela theories are
enough to put FBI director Christopher Wray and
other top national security officials on alert
for the risk that the former president's most
ardent supporters might again resort to violence.
Now we're already seeing dates move around what
was once August 13th. Now some people say will be
August 21st. Why will August 21st? Trump will be
speaking at a rally in Cullman, Alabama. One rumor
of new, I guess you could call it a new delusion
is that Trump will be reinstated at that rally. By
who? How? It's not exactly clear because it will
never happen. And the shifting of the date is very
much like the end of the world rapture people.
I've interviewed some of these people, there's
always some date it doesn't happen. So they shift
the date. They say, oh, we misread the signals or
God changed his mind or something was out of
context. And then they come up with a new date.
I don't know that it will prevent the violence,
but it needs to be somehow put in these people's
minds that Trump just lost. It's an Occam's razor.
The simplest explanation is the one that applies.
The election was certified. Joe Biden was the
winner and he was sworn in. Donald Trump is not
in the line of succession. If the president goes,
then it goes to the VP and if the VP goes bye bye,
then it's the speaker of the House and so on.
Trump is not part of that. The last president
is not part of that. And some others are saying
now very directly, as I told you yesterday,
that it will be September and they're going to the
capital. So I think the risk for violence is real
for me. Is Trump really getting reinstated
is not the right question. It's it's a silly
question. Of course he's not. The real question
is will there be violence? And I'm worried that
there will be a will pick up on that much more in
future shows. And let's hope it doesn't happen.